quanti di voi hanno acquistato alexa all
assistente google e che cosa ci fate vi
domandate soltanto informazioni sul
tempo che ora è quando ci sarà il
prossimo treno per torino ad esempio
oppure vi rivolgete anche domande più
personali e domandate come sta
se vi vuole bene il tema che ha pronto e
questo si può amare un robot si può
essere coinvolti da un sistema operativo
si può provare un sentimento di affetto
nei confronti di una macchina ci sono
diversi film che ci raccontano della
relazione tra esseri umani e robot
questa immagine sono sicuro la
riconoscerete eb liberarne il film di
ridley scott il cacciatore di umanoidi
di android si innamora perde la testa
per race anche sera cell è una macchina
anche negli ultimi anni sono stati
raccontati nei film diversi modi appunto
di relazionarsi con le macchine e ne è
stata raccontata anche dettagliatamente
quanto può essere forte quanto può
essere forte il coinvolgimento che
proviamo nei confronti di una macchina o
addirittura di un sistema operativo il
film lei ci racconta proprio appunto di
quanto possa essere facile perdere la
testa per un programma il protagonista
di lei è un uomo solo che viene da una
separazione che si trova a doversi
ricostruire da zero la propria esistenza
trova in un sistema operativo l'altro
che può aiutarlo ad uscire da questa
situazione di sofferenza di solitudine e
quello che il
ci racconta e che piano piano questo
coinvolgimento diventa sempre più forte
alla fine il protagonista si innamora
del sistema operativo di samantha e non
ha nessuna vergogna di raccontare pero
che amici che ora si ora una nuova
compagna ora è di nuovo felice perché ha
ritrovato finalmente lavoro
peccato che il sistema operativo allo
stesso tempo ami anche più di 8.000
altri utenti nel nel film lei c'è un
problema per il protagonista il sistema
operativo non ha un corpo quindi si
presentano sicuramente dei problemi
perché appunto non può vivere appieno il
protagonista questa storia d amore con
con la macchina nel film ex machina le
cose cambiano perché il robot è la
macchina presenta invece un corpo anche
in questo caso il film ci racconta di
una storia d'amore che nasce tra un
essere umano è un robot
il robot se si mostra così seduttivo che
basta poco che l'essere umano il
protagonista del film non non è più
capace di resistere appunto alla
tentazione viene coinvolto
sentimentalmente dal dalla macchina
esistono quindi nel nei film nei romanzi
di fantascienza diversi esempi di
relazioni tra macchine e ed esseri umani
ma queste cose non accadono soltanto nei
film di fantascienza le osserviamo anche
nella vita di tutti i giorni
molti di voi ricorderanno ad esempio il
tamagotchi questo dispositivo
elettronico in cui che permetteva di
giocare con un esserino che compariva
gli esseri umani che volevano interi di
interagire con questo dispositivo che
cosa dovevano fare dovevano prendersi
cura di queste serino del tamagotchi
cosa significa che cosa significava che
ha
pre determinate ore della giornata
dovevano dargli da mangiare dovevano
coccolare coccolarlo dovevano prendersi
cura di lui e ci sono diversi aneddoti
sul sulle persone che utilizzavano
questo dispositivo ad esempio si
racconta che alcune persone e sono scesi
di corsa dall'aereo arrabbiate con il
personale della compagnia aerea perché
le hostess avevano chiesto loro di
spegnere il dispositivo
cosa che per loro significava lasciar
morire ad uccidere il il tamagotchi lo
stesso la stessa capacità di costruire
una relazione con le macchine la
osserviamo anche oggi in ambito in
ambito ospedaliero e nell'ambito
dell'assistenza agli anziani oggi
incominciano ad essere presenti in negli
ospedali o nelle case di riposo dei
robot che assistono e che interagiscono
con gli esseri umani con i pazienti e le
persone anziane
quello che si è osservato è che queste
persone nel tempo costruiscono una
relazione nei confronti delle macchine
provano un affetto si interessano al
loro benessere poi uno che stiano che
stiano bene e cercano addirittura di
dati da mangiare a volte queste macchine
funzionano male perché queste queste
persone cercano di dar loro da mangiare
di dar loro dei biscotti e questo fa
funzionare fa funzionare male le
macchine e queste persone vogliono
sapere come funzionano i robot si
interessano ai meccanismi che ci sono
dietro al loro funzionamento quindi a
livello cognitivo razionale sanno
perfettamente che si tratta di macchine
malgrado questo essi si lasciano
coinvolgere sentimentalmente da da
questi robot e iniziano a volergli bene
come fossero degli esseri viventi come
se fossero qualcosa di più che semplici
oggetti la domanda interessante per un
film
della morale se in futuro noi tenderemo
ad attribuire personalità morale e
giuridica alle macchine a riconoscere
loro rilevanza morale a considerare
sbagliato ad esempio maltrattarle
prenderli a calci ridurli a un in
schiavi o trattarle come urgenti la
domanda è legittima e la risposta può
essere semplice se immaginiamo che un
domani i robot saranno entità
intelligenti e capaci di essere
coscienti di se stessi ed in grado di
provare sentimenti di sentire dolore e
provare piacere
a quel punto saranno sicuramente delle
persone per riconoscere un robot come
persona però secondo me non è necessario
non sarà necessario che il robot di 20
auto cosciente basterà che sia in grado
di interagire con noi come farebbe un
altro essere vivente in grado di
cogliere il nostro umore e quindi di
relazionarsi a noi in maniera
appropriata a seconda appunto dello
stato d'animo che di volta in volta
viviamo ad esempio appunto se torniamo a
casa il robot capisce anche sulla base
delle informazioni che ha raccolto
durante la giornata o dal nostro
comportamento che noi non siamo felici
il robot dovrà compiere una serie di
operazioni se il robot sarà in grado di
fare questo se sarà in grado di
empatizzare con noi
secondo me noi non sapremo resistere
alla tentazione di attribuire a queste
macchine una grande rilevanza morale a
riconoscerle come membri della nostra
comunità morale
chiaramente si può poi ragionare sul
valore di questa relazione se questa
relazione con le macchine una relazione
autentica oppure no che cosa potremmo
perdere nel relazionarci troppo con un
robot programmato ad agire in un certo
modo con il robot comunque non soltanto
possiamo costruire delle relazioni
ma possiamo anche praticare del sesso il
robot può essere anche un oggetto
sessuale l'oggetto delle nostre fantasie
sessuali
qui la domanda morale è semplice c'è
qualcosa di male nel fare sesso con un
robot a prima vista la risposta è facile
fare sesso con un robot significa
praticare autoerotismo
se non c'è nulla di male nel raggiungere
il piacere da soli allora non c'è
nemmeno nulla di male da un punto di
vista morale nel praticare sesso nel
raggiungere il piacere con l'aiuto di un
robot fino a poco tempo fa si poteva
pensare che loud erotismo era qualcosa
di inaccettabile da un punto di vista
morale
si pensava che l'unico modo di usare
correttamente i propri organi genitali
forse in relazione con un altro essere
umano è soltanto per finalità
riproduttive oggi lo scenario culturale
completamente cambiato e nessuno ritiene
che raggiungere il piacere da soli sia
qualcosa di sbagliato da un punto di
vista morale
ci sono però delle preoccupazioni che
emergono quando pensiamo a questo
scenario in cui gli esseri umani possono
avere sesso possono fare sesso con con
una macchina ad esempio alcuni
sostengono che soltanto persone viziose
potrebbero avere il coraggio di
acquistare e consumare un rapporto con
un robot con una macchina quello che si
dice che soltanto persone che presentano
devianze e fantasie immorali o che hanno
problemi relazionali che non riescono a
costruire rapporti con un'altra persona
possono potrebbero avere il coraggio di
acquistare di fare sesso con con una
macchina
l'altra preoccupazione che che facendo
sesso avendo rapporti con una macchina
il carattere delle persone potrebbe
corrompersi le persone potrebbero
disabituarsi ad avere rapporti
rispettosi dell'altro
i robot non possono esprimere consenso
alcuni robot sono costruiti per dare
l'impressione di negare il consenso
ci sono alcune persone che vogliono
vivere attraverso i robot l'esperienza
di una violenza ed è per questo che sono
in commercio robot di questi tipi
programmati per dire di no e quindi
quello che che si teme che a forza di
relazionarsi con robot programmati in
questo modo privi della capacità di
esprimere consenso o che esprimono un
rifiuto del rapporto alle persone
possono sviluppare potrebbero sviluppare
disposizioni violenti aggressive nei
confronti del proprio partner e in
particolare nei confronti delle donne
queste sono sicuramente preoccupazioni
legittime che chi si occupa di robotica
deve considerare quello che si può dire
che posso che posso affermare è che
forse riguardo all'uso dei sex robot
possiamo immaginare tante situazioni in
cui l'uso di queste macchine non appare
affatto qualcosa di vizioso di morale ci
possono essere persone che sono
interessate ad un sex robot perché hanno
perso il proprio partner o perché
vengono da una separazione non hanno
voglia di incominciare una nuova
relazione altre persone potrebbero avere
fantasie così eccentrica ed originali
che non riescono a vivere con il proprio
partner
queste persone potrebbero avere appunto
dei compagni dei partner che non hanno
voglia che non possono assecondare le
proprie le proprie fantasie per alcune
persone poi può essere il sex robot una
consolazione ci sono persone che
soffrono di particolari ansie sociali
che non riescono a costruire una
relazione con altre persone perché sono
troppo troppo timide il sex robot
potrebbe essere appunto un aiuto
temporaneo nella speranza appunto che
piano piano queste persone possano
superare le proprie difficoltà e anche
su questo tema c'è un bellissimo film
lars e una ragazza tutta per sé che
racconta
già proprio del contributo che il sex
robot in quel caso che una bambola di
silicone può dare ad una persona che
vive un problema personale che però non
è un vizio non è qualcosa di criticabile
moralmente ma è un problema psicologico
c'è una considerazione che che fa vda al
woody allen sosteneva che faceva bene
l'amore perché si era esercitato tanto
da solo
non so se questo sia vero se woody allen
abbia ragione probabilmente però il sex
robot potrebbero in futuro presentarsi
anche come strumenti educativi che
potrebbero aiutare le generazioni future
ad avvicinarsi alla sessualità in modo
in modo appropriato per quanto riguarda
invece la paura che il sex robot possa
corrompere il carattere dell'utente qui
si tratta di una preoccupazione che che
va presa appunto come dicevo in seria
considerazione però non abbiamo ancora
la possibilità non abbiamo ancora dati
che ci permettano di trarre una
conclusione in riguardo appunto a questa
a questa questione sex robot sono un
fenomeno relativamente recente
non sappiamo se giocare con i sex robot
potrebbe farci diventare delle persone
più aggressive più violente
sappiamo però che praticare videogiochi
non rende necessariamente le persone più
violente e sappiamo anche che consumare
pornografia non impedisce
necessariamente di avere relazioni
rispettose del proprio partner e
dell'altra persona
se applichiamo quello che noi sappiamo
sui videogiochi violenti e sulla
pornografia ai sex robot forse la
preoccupazione che i sex robot possano
corrompere il carattere risulta meno
intuitivamente meno plausibile
accettabile di quanto a prima vista
possa sembrare
d'altra parte quanti di noi da bambini
hanno giocato ai cowboy e agli indiani
quando io ero bambino ucciso uccideva
ogni giorno tanti bambini al gioco
ovviamente ma questo come ricorda
albinati nella scuola cattolica non ci
ha reso dei serial killer
il gioco è una cosa la funzione una cosa
le fantasie sono una cosa la realtà è
un'altra cosa la maggior parte di noi è
in grado di entrare e uscire con
facilità da questi ambiti senza senza
confonderli
l'ultima cosa che vorrei dire riguarda
comunque il fatto che per il momento i
robot i sex robot vengono costruiti
prevalentemente con le fattezze di una
donna quindi c'è sicuramente il rischio
il pericolo che la produzione e la messa
in commercio dei sex robot possa
promuovere l'idea della donna come
oggetto dobbiamo però considerare che
incominciano ad essere presenti anche
modelli maschili rivolti a un pubblico
diciamo più ampio non soltanto a uomini
ma anche a donne e che si prevede che in
futuro i robot i sex robot potranno
essere sempre di più personalizzabili e
questo quello che sta emergendo questo
potrebbe aiutare a liberare le nostre
fantasie sessuali anche a sperimentare
in forme di sessualità più originali non
legate necessariamente a un determinato
genere
naturalmente si tratta di temi di temi
difficili e capisco che davanti a
scenari che propongono sex robot e la
possibilità di costruire relazioni con i
robot si possa provare un forte
sentimento di ripugnanza dobbiamo però
tener conto che questa è una reazione
che sorge naturalmente di fronte alle
nuove tecnologie
succede spesso è successo in passato con
le tecnologie riproduttive e con altre
tecnologie
che succede oggi con la robotica il
fatto che l'oggetto si presenti per la
prima volta alla nostra percezione al
nostro sguardo genera paura
quello che sappiamo è che questi
sentimenti questi sentimenti forti con
il tempo si indeboliscono e si spengono
e permettono di raggiungere una
condizione
diciamo di maggiore oggettività e di
maggior capacità di confrontarsi con i
vantaggi e gli svantaggi delle nuove
tecnologie
[Applauso]